my lord might I go as well does al
Starla keep the old gods no my lord I
was named in the light of the seven as
my father was and his father before him
why would you forsake the gods of your
father and your house the realm do you
know what the realm is it's the thousand
blades of Aegon's enemies a story we
agreed to tell each other over and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's odd ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
in today's video I want to talk about
our old friend same ol Tarly the last
time we saw this character was in the
season 7 finale when he helped brain
stark uncover the truth about Jon Snow's
parents what I mainly want to talk about
today is what actually lied same ol
Tarly to this moment I don't know if any
of you have noticed or not but Sam is no
ordinary character or at least not in
this sense then many people may think
Sam might not have any magical powers
but in my opinion it does seem like Sam
has been given a magical layer of
protection to a certain extent there is
a example of this happening in almost
every season of the show so my main
question is were the old gods protecting
Samwell Tarly the whole time it seems
like someone or something is trying to
keep Sam alive for a very specific
reason this is what I want to discuss
today so let's get into it let's start
off the video when Sam killed the first
white Walker with his dragonglass dagger
most of these scenes do play out very
differently in the books but just for
the sake of this video let's just stick
to what happened in a television show
what happened in this scene when Sam
killed the white Walker is what led me
to make them the video and I'll tell you
why for those of you that don't remember
this is when Sam Gilly and the baby were
traveling to the wall together at the
time they stopped at a small cabin to
get some shelter for the night when they
arrived there just so happen to be a
weirwood tree at that location and I do
not think that was a coincidence after
they go inside the cabin Gilly is able
to get a fire started for them for the
night but then something starts to
happen shortly after that about a
thousand crows start to land on the
weirwood tree right out
out of the door when the crows land on
the tree they all begin to shriek which
obviously gets Gillian Sam's attention
the reason why the crows started to do
this was to let them know that the white
Walker was on his way some of you may or
may not know this but those crows were
sent by the three-eyed raven we have
seen brain stark do this as well but
before bran became the new three-eyed
raven it was the three-eyed raven from
the cave that was controlling most of
the animals in the earlier seasons like
I said the three-eyed Raven was trying
to get Sam's attention before the white
Walker got too close to the cabin but
why did he do this
why was the three-eyed Raven trying to
help Sam and Gilly in my opinion at the
very least Sam was getting some
protection from the old gods because he
obviously has a much bigger part to play
in the end game just as a side note when
I'm referring to the old gods I am
referring to the weirwood trees the
children of the forest and the
three-eyed Raven now I know some of you
might be thinking maybe they are just
trying to protect the Nights Watch in
general because they are the ones that
guard the wall but I do not think that
is the case let's go back to the very
first scene in the very first episode of
the show when we see the men of the
Nights Watch go out beyond the wall to
track the wildlings as we all know some
of those men end up getting killed by
the White Walkers I don't remember
seeing any crows in that scene trying to
alert the men that the White Walkers
were coming but for some reason they did
do that for Sam now even though the
three-eyed raven did not give them any
noticeable assistance to any of those
men this scene did have a very big
impact on the story if that man did not
get beheaded on that day the Starks may
have never found those dire wolves now
the reason why I want to talk about that
scene is because the three-eyed Raven
also played a part he was the one that
sent the pregnant direwolves south of
the wall so the Starks could find her in
the pumps they did not just find them at
random they were a gift from the old
gods and there is a lot of evidence of
this in the books not only do all the
direwolves had the same eye color as the
children of the forest and the
three-eyed Raven but ghost actually
looks just like a weirwood tree which is
pretty interesting later in the books
and one of John's chapters he notices
the similarities between his direwolf
ghost and the weirwood trees John says
red eyes John realized but not like
Melisandre he had a where woods eyes red
eyes red mouth white fur blood and bone
like a heart tree he belongs to the old
gods this one
and he alone of all the direwolves was
white six pups they found in the late
summer snows Hammond Rob five that were
gray in black and brown for the five
Starks and one white as white as snow so
as you can see this was no accident
those dire wolves were sent from the old
gods in order to give the stark some
extra protection just like he does with
the crows the three-eyed Raven went
inside of the mother dire wolf and he
took her south of the wall near
Winterfell for the Starks to find now I
say all that to say this
ghost wasn't just protecting Jon Snow
but he also had a very close
relationship with Saemaul Tarly but why
there are a bunch of different men at
Castle black that were friends with Jon
Snow
but none of them were as close what
ghost as Sam was and I think this has to
be for a very specific reason which was
to keep Sam alive when Sam and Jon get
the crest risky this is where Sam
obviously meets Gilly for the first time
eventually there is a scene when ghost
walks up the Gilly and scare sir but Sam
is able to tell ghost what to do no
ghosts no no that's the way choo-choo
this is interesting because we really
don't see anyone else give ghost
commands besides Jon ghost actually
listens to Sam because as I said they
also have a close relationship almost as
if ghost is a protector of Sam as well
we see it happen again when Castle black
comes under attack when Sam and Jon are
taking the elevator down Jon knows that
he needs to give the key to Sam so Sam
can let go style to help them fight the
wildlings
[Music]
we need you both
[Music]
once again Sam gives ghost the command
and he listens the same again now the
best example of this is when John Snow
is actually not even around when John is
on his way to hardhome Sam and Gilly run
into some trouble at Castle black some
of the other men of the Nights Watch
attempt to rape Gilly that night Sam
does his best to protect her but he gets
his ass kicked pretty bad and the men
might have even killed Sam so they could
rape Gilly
but once again ghost is nearby
[Music]
no one tells ghosts to go in there and
do that he does it on his own so now
it's quite clear that ghost is also
looking out for Sam as well what makes
him so special over all the other men of
the Nights Watch
I think Samwell Tarly may have been
chosen in the very first season of the
show
when it was time for John and Sam to say
their Night's Watch vows Sam made a
critical decision that may have had a
very big impact on his story from there
on out as we all know Jon Snow spent his
life praying to the old gods he actually
grew up what the weirwood tree right in
his backyard but same ol Tarly did not
Sam used to pray to the 7 but all of
that started to change when Sam joined
the Nights Watch my lord might I go as
well as house Tarly keep the old gods no
my lord
the Nights Watch is my house and help
seven have never answered my prayers
perhaps the old gods will as you wish
that's when Sam started to take the old
gods more seriously in fact when Sam
took his knights watched vowels
he did it in front of the weirwood tree
with Jon Snow right by his side in my
opinion when Sam decided to do that with
Jon Snow it did create a link between
those two characters that went much
deeper than just your ordinary
friendship I think this was the day when
the old God started to protect Samwell
Tarly just as much as they did with Jon
Snow many other men of the Nights Watch
have said their vows in front of that
tree before
Benjen stark being one of them but it
was Sam's connection to Jon Snow the
Song of Ice and Fire
that made the difference this created a
very special bond between these two
characters that has not been broken this
protection allowed Sam to do some of the
things that he was able to do and
survive some of the things that he was
able to survive all of this led to the
moment that Sam and bran would meet each
other and eventually work together now
let's go back to the scene when Sam
kills the white Walker
the only reason Sam was able to kill the
white Walker was because he had that
dragonglass dagger but how did Sam end
up what that dagger was a by accident or
did something put him in position to
getting it when Sam gren and Ed were at
the fist of the first men they were
digging into the snow and this is when
they end up finding a very old Night's
Watch cloak buried in the snow after
they dig it out they open up the cloak
and this is when they find the
dragonglass weapons along with what
could be the Horn of winter them finding
this stuff was no accident
once again Sam just happened to be at
the right place at the right time
because that dagger would end up saving
his life when the white Walker came now
what happens after Sam kills the white
Walker with the dagger Sam and Gilly end
up finding a secret gate that allows
them to get to the other side of the
wall but who do they run into as they
are doing this this is when Sam and bran
meet for the first time not only does
Sam show them how to get to the other
side of the wall so brain can find the
three-eyed raven but Sam also does give
them some dragon class this is a very
important moment in this show because it
would lead to Sam and bran working
together in the final season of the show
everything that happened to say
and put him one step closer to meeting
up what brain again in the final season
these two characters were meant to work
together Sam even told bran I know that
John Snow is meant to lead the fight
against the night king and now that he's
working with bran
together they will uncover the truth
about how to defeat the night king now
some people could say some of the things
that did happen Sam was just a
coincidence but in my opinion all of
that was set in motion the day that he
said his vows with Jon Snow in front of
the weirwood tree from that day on the
old gods of the north took special
interest in saying Walter Lee but let me
know what you think do you agree with
that or do you think something else
happened put your thoughts or questions
down below in the comment section I want
to thank everyone for stopping by and
watching today's video
I really appreciate that and I also want
to thank all of my supporters on patreon
I hope everyone has a great day I will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you